[Music]
[Applause]
megan the stallion brought body otti to
the grammys with this old hollywood
inspired dance number
[Music]
it was a 26 year old houston native's
first time joining music's biggest night
and it wouldn't be right if she didn't
make it savage
meg performed her now grammy
award-winning song savage remix
featuring beyonce
and although queen bee didn't join her
on stage for the performance
she was right there by her side after
they won best rap song for the hit
i just want to quickly give my love to
megan i have so much respect for you
and i'm honored that you asked me to be
a part of the song and i just want to
say houston we love you thank you
grammys
thank you earlier in the day megan and
beyonce made history by becoming the
first pair of women to win in the best
rat performance category
also for savage remix and the grammy
goes to
savage megan the stallion featuring
beyonce
[Applause]
the body rapper was also crowned best
new artist taking her current grammy win
total to three
et's kevin frazier spoke with megan
after her big night first and foremost
how does it feel to be holding those
grammys
it feels amazing i couldn't believe i
was here when i got here and i
definitely can't believe i'm leaving
here with 3ds
did you have any idea beyonce was
sitting down there literally
i looked and i was like there's is that
fiance that's beyonce
so every time i see beyonce i get
excited like i've never seen her before
what how cool was that that she was
there to have that moment with you
it was just such an epic moment um
beyonce is a treasure to everybody in
houston
pretty sure to everybody in the world
but specifically from where we're from
we just live
absolutely love beyonce and to have her
like just seal the deal for me
like it's like a pat on the back like i
am proud of you girl i'm like
thank you and she set a record tonight
how important was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
black women in general we're here we're
here to stay
we're here to take over we've been doing
that but
like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight
all right one other thing that
performance tonight y'all hung it you
let it all
out there i did it yes you did i feel
like i really wanted it to be like black
hollywood
um i had to have my female tappers they
were great
my men were out there they were amazing
we spent so many weeks
i feel like it was a whole month
preparing for this performance and to
see it all come together i'm so happy
hmm where you partying tonight where are
you how are you gonna celebrate
we're just gonna do a whole lot of hot
girl tonight